so President Trump is at a pretty rough
two-week stretch how is it possible that
the left is blowing it like completely
blowing it we will explain in four
simple steps how the left is destroying
itself I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show okay so many a thing to
discuss but the truth is that the left
is really destroying its own capacity to
stop President Trump you know they've
been whining and bitching about
President Trump consistently ever since
his election and far before and now they
finally have a two-week period where
Trump is just a gaffe machine you just
going out and saying silly thing after
silly thing and the left can't stop
themselves they can't stop themselves
because their end game here their entire
endgame is to castigate all of their
political opponents as Nazis and Trump
sycophants and in their pursuit of this
endgame they've forgotten they don't
actually need to do that in order to win
so we're gonna discuss how in four
simple steps they're alienating the
American people how it is that they are
taking the president who has right now a
34% popularity rating and possibly
boosting him to reelected reelection
victory and how it's very possible they
may not even went back the house will
talk about all of that but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
ProFlowers so last time I was away on
travel I decided that it would be a good
idea to send my wife flowers I do this a
lot when I'm away on travel but the only
company that I trusted to do this is
proflowers.com right now you get 20% off
of any of their unique summer rose
bouquets or any other bouquet of $29 or
more they're colorful rainbow roses
always a hit if you don't know what to
send I sent them I think a couple of
weeks ago to my wife the ProFlowers
bouquets are guaranteed to stay fresh
for at least seven days or your money
back and you control the delivery date
if something breaks they'll correct it
right away we actually had a vase break
and they immediately sent a replacement
ProFlowers gives you more bloom for your
buck big beautiful flowers with more
stems for your money right now if you
want to get 20% off summer roses or any
other bouquet of twenty nine dollars or
more go to proflowers.com use my code
Ben's show at checkout GoPro flowers and
Ben Ben show and check out you get a
bedding bouquet of $29 more you get a
20% discount on they are beautiful and
they really do last means much better
than store-bought that's proflowers.com
and use that code Ben show it'll
definitely make your spouse's or your
girlfriend's day make sure that you do
that mom's day and
but it's good for all relatives who
enjoy flowers proflowers.com and use
that promo code been show to get 20% off
also that lets them know that we sent
you okay so the Democrats are coming off
a two-week period where the President of
the United States pretended he didn't
know what the alt-right was and then
said that there were very fine people at
a torchlight rally with white
supremacists and they're somehow losing
somehow they're losing see this is the
amazing thing you look at the polling
data right now at the polling data shows
is in North Carolina for example poll
yesterday Trump would still beat Hillary
Clinton 43 39 and this was the case all
throughout the election cycle and
there's been a lot of talk for the last
two years about how the elections the
polls they're all a referendum on Trump
the world revolves around Trump Trump is
our son and we all revolve around him in
planetary orbit the reality is that the
last election cycle was not about Trump
the last election cycle is about Hillary
Clinton Donald Trump just showed how
unpopular Hillary Clinton is that's all
that election cycle was it wasn't about
Trump being some genius god-king it
wasn't about forty chests upside down
underwater Hungry Hungry Hippos mega
mega mega it wasn't about any of that
stuff is about Hillary Clinton is the
least appealing human being ever to walk
the planet Hillary Clinton makes the
white walkers on Game of Thrones look as
though they are attractive date
prospects okay Hillary Clinton was a
garbage candidate she was such a bad
candidate that this is real statistic
okay Donald Trump one fewer votes in
Wisconsin than Mitt Romney did in 2012
and he won the state Hillary Clinton no
one likes her okay so what that means
and you looked at the polls all during
the election cycle and what you saw was
Trump was very consistent always between
40 and 43 percent the entire election
until he got to 46 right at the end
Hillary Clinton was bouncing around
between 50 and 39 15 and 30 nets have
really broad range it's a really broad
range so what Democrats seem to neglect
and all of their hatred of Trump is that
they have to not suck and they are
failing at this very simple task of not
sucking and there are four ways that
they are failing at this very simple
test so the first thing they do is they
pick unpopular issues so recall all the
way back to last week when President
Trump gave his ridiculous press
conference after he had already given a
press conference where he made a very
good statement about why he doesn't like
the KKK and neo-nazis this is a one-foot
pipe okay does it happen the next day he
comes out and he says well what I said
yesterday
um no no and say he does that for no
reason and all his advisors are saying
dude what like John Kelly is looking
around and saying to himself I can't
believe this is my life now everyone is
wondering what he's doing so the
Democrats have a great talking point
they have a great talking point I can
cut the Democrat ad for them okay the
Democratic ad is Donald Trump say okay
it's a clip from the Charlottesville
rally the Friday night Charlottesville
rally with all of the white supremacists
and Richard Spencer and people chanting
Jews aren't will not replace us and then
a clip of Donald's from saying very fine
people or at that and then a clip of
Donald Trump with ex congressional
candidate shaking his hand that's the ad
Frankie ad writes itself it's the
easiest thing in the world so what do
the Democrats do they do the thing that
they are the best at they are
unbelievably stupid they decide that
what is deeply important is to talk
about Confederate statues right this is
what they're gonna talk about
Confederate statues so they move from an
issue where 95% of the population agrees
neo-nazis bad and they move instead to
an issue where 50% of the population
thinks they're wrong okay there's a
Quinnipiac poll that came out yesterday
showed 50 percent of Americans don't
want to get rid of these Confederate
memorials or don't care about it and 39
percent say they want to get rid of them
so what are the media choose to do what
is the left choose to do let's talk
about Confederate memorials you
understand how it done this is there's
now a cataclysmically stupid this is
okay it's it's incredible and it's
exactly what the alt-right wanted why do
you think the alt-right rallied around a
robert e lee statue you think they did
it cuz they really care that deeply
about a robert e lee statue
the reason the alt right and white
supremacists rallied around the robert e
lee's statue is because they were
attempting to demonstrate to the public
that there was a broad swath of people
who agree with them there aren't a broad
swath of people who agree with them but
there are a lot of people who agree with
them on the Confederate statue issue for
different reasons not because they think
that slavery was great like some of the
members of the white supremacist groups
believe but because they believe that
this is part of American history don't
wipe away American history just because
it's uncomfortable so one of the
Democrats do what do what is the left do
they decide that it is imperative that
we have this out right now they did the
same thing after Dylann storm roof right
Dylann storm roof goes and he and he
shoots up a black church and he kills
what was it 19 people something like
that and I can't remember the exact
number he pills I think it was 19 or 20
people he kills an enormous number of
people
murders them in cold blood he's a white
promises peace of human feces so what do
we do do we talk about why white
supremacism is bad no we have a
nationwide conversation about the
confederate flag which literally
millions of people do not hold in
contempt and do not think connect with
white supremacism because the left
constantly is trying to broaden out
their agenda
they can't just target the people we all
agree suck they have to instead try to
lump in all of the people they don't
like with all the people that we all
agree suck but they have to make that
into one giant group so their first step
first step in the democratic failures
they pick unpopular issues so here are
two issues that are unpopular they
affect they've picked the Confederate
flag issue and they're the Confederate
statue issue even Chris Matthews don't
ever say and Chris Matthew God comes at
a show right even he recognizes that all
of this stuff about the Confederate
statues has no limiting principle
meaning that the same people who want to
rip down the Confederate statues want to
get rid of the Washington statues as
Trump said and the Jefferson statues and
now they want to get rid of the Columbus
statue in Columbus Circle in New York if
the reason there's a statue to
Christopher Columbus is because it was a
great thing for the world that Western
civilization discovered the Americas it
was ok it wasn't a great thing for a lot
of people who are living there but it's
a great thing for the world history the
Western civilization ended up
discovering the Americas which were a
primitive place filled with peoples who
had no concept of modern civilization it
doesn't mean Christopher Columbus and
wonderful guy doesn't mean he didn't
commit any sins doesn't mean he didn't
enslave the natives dated all of these
terrible things but that's not what
we're celebrating when we celebrate
Columbus Day we're celebrating the fact
that Western civilization is good even
though there are evil things that
Western civilization has done hey but
the entire movements ripped down these
statues it's all about attempting to
wipe away any history that people find
gross because they can't just
acknowledge Western here's the thing
here's the big disagreement there are a
lot of people like me who say Western
civilization is the the greatest
civilization in the history of the
planet bar none by far not close and
there are grains of evil embedded in it
and we have spent most of our history
trying to wipe those away gradually and
then there are people on the other side
who say Western civilization is bad and
racism and bigotry and slavery these are
inherent parts of the foundations of
Western civilization and that's why
Western civilization is bad so for
people like me I look at the Columbus
statue or Washington statue or Jefferson
statue
or even Ali statue and I say this was
all part of our history and it's
important that we respect the history
enough to discuss it because this is all
part of building a civilization even the
nasty parts are part of building a
civilization is what I think Katrina
Pierson was trying to say although she
said it badly the other night and the
left says all of these things are bad
Washington is bad because Western
civilization is bad it's racist sexist
bigoted homophobe and Columbus is bad
but even Chris Matthews recognizes that
this is a stupid move by Democrats but
they're engaging in too anyway here's
Chris Matthews over LACC stay explaining
why shouldn't talk in Paris that what's
going on you know but Kathleen explain
go nobody's going after Teddy Teddy
Roosevelt and the idea of going after
slave owners you'd have to basically
take away our history because the first
six presents are so had slaves you'd
have to go after people like Washington
and of course all the southern guys all
the ones who found him Madison and of
course some Monroe and the rest and of
course Old Hickory because it was Indian
fighting and killing where do we stop
where do we stop it saying that we're
gonna recognize it for what it was and
move on and when are we gonna say no
some it has to be D celebrated taken
away from our sight okay one of the
things that's fascinating here is
there's a great divide between Chris
Matthews Democrats and Al Sharpton
Democrats and it seems as though the
Democratic Party is moving in the
direction of Al Sharpton Democrats not
Chris Matthews Democrats Matthews is
much more like Joe Biden he's a crazy
old kook who talks about coming somebody
show but he actually has a concept of
what people in Middle America are
thinking people like Al Sharpton don't
and so they are ensconced in this I had
a discussion with Don Lemon last night
on CNN and I explained to him that you
know just because the media people like
Don Lemon see the Confederate statue
issue as black and white no racial
connotation it's just a black and white
issue evil versus non evil that doesn't
mean that's how Americans see it and
moving in that direction is actually a
large mistake so that's one issue step
one again for the Democrats it's pick
unpopular issues instead of popular ones
here's another unpopular issue they've
chosen to pick there are hundreds of
people assuming these are all members of
the left not a lot of members of the
right who would do this
who are rallying outside NFL
headquarters because of Colin Kaepernick
who is a garbage quarterback okay he had
the worst quarterback rating of any
back in the league two years ago he put
like five games last year before he was
benched in favor of basically some sort
of poodle I mean they he was such a bad
quarterback that they basically took an
inanimate object and stuck it behind
Center for the 49ers until he lost his
job so there's been this big rallying
effect around Kaepernick and Democrats
are pushing this I'll explain that issue
in one second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at wink
so does everything that you are seeing
right now make you wanna get drunk
does it well I have the proper solution
for you over at wink comm what they can
do is they can actually personalize the
best wines your palate so this is
actually better for dinner parties this
is great if you don't know anything
about wine if you think that
Manischewitz is good wine then you
actually need to go over to link comm
and get some really good wine because
the way that it works is you go over
there you take a brief palate quiz and
they tell you which one best matches
your palate and what best matches the
meal that you are about to go to so
you're gonna go to a friend's house you
don't want to look like an ignoramus
because you picked up some Schlitz
instead you should probably go over to
link comm and you should pick up some
wine from wing comm every bottle is like
999 it's try winked calm T ry wi and
see.com take that palette profile quiz
and they will recommend distinct and
interesting wines tailored to you again
it's tri wink comm / ben if you go to
slash Ben you get $20 off your first
order plus free shipping it's try blink
comm slash Ben try wink comm slash Ben t
ry winc comm slash spending at $20 off
your first order right now people around
the office we did a wine tasting for
everybody around the office they've been
drunk ever since which explains the
quality of the show lately try winked
comm / Ben $20 off your first order
right now and the wine I have been told
is glorious I've been told that by my
sloshed employees okay so the other from
the other issue that the Democrats have
chosen to focus on in the last two weeks
instead of discussing wine neo-nazism is
bad god you people are morons is they've
decided to talk about colin kaepernick a
guy who kneels from the national anthem
which is the only reason anyone thinks
he's important
you know many second string quarterbacks
in him in America lose their job every
year a lot of NFL quarterbacks lose
their job every year because they suck
it happens a lot okay Tim Tebow lost his
job even though he took his team to the
playoffs after winning a series of games
he couldn't throw a forward pass and so
people said okay we're not going to give
him a job anymore and now he's playing
baseball for the like
say in New York Matt's essentially the
the the left though has decided that
colin kaepernick despite being world's
crappiest quarterback must have a job
you wonder why people like me stopped
watching ESPN maybe it's because I got
sick of ESPN devoting its entire channel
to explaining why a guy who's barely
drafted in the seventh round Michael Sam
had to be employed in the NFL and now
they're devoting all of their time to
why a guy who can't throw a pass in the
NFL being through some of the worst
passes of the year last year
must have a job because he kneeled for
the national anthem so tareka nasheed
who has the IQ of a kumquat he tweeted
out yesterday I'm with cap because white
supremacy is not patriotism and he wrote
those all with capital letters and on
different lines I don't know if that's
supposed to be some sort of acronym but
I'm not sure what wsin P or whatever
that was stands for Eugene gue MD no
idea who this guy is says blacklisting
Kaepernick is completely on American
improves why his protest is necessary
hashtag on with cap maybe he's not being
blacklisted maybe he stinks maybe he's
thinks it's funny all the same people
who are complaining that Kaepernick is
being blacklisted laughed when people
said the Tebow was being blacklisted
Susan Sarandon Bernie Sanders devotee
she says rally in support of Colin
Kaepernick in front of NFL together we
win I stand with Colin okay well if you
stand with Colin you're worth a fair bit
of money while you pay him why don't you
give him why don't you give him a job
Susan I mean still have a lot of
Atlantic City money left over you can
sell some of those oranges I'm sure on
eBay
Trayvon free Travon free Trayvon free he
posted a picture that says NFL and it
says Negro fall in line not even a good
acronym because he had it's really NF il
which doesn't make any sense
is loving the signs today hashtag I'm
with cap yeah these are all just protest
signs in favor of Colin Kaepernick again
Charles Clymer says white people do not
own patriotism hashtag I'm with cap well
I mean I I have a feeling that it's not
a black or white issue but if you kneel
from the national anthem I'm gonna say
that you probably don't get to claim
patriotism I mean like the again there
are certain unifying symbols the
national anthem is one of them either
see America is a good development that
is moving in a direction toward
perfecting its ills or a see America is
inherently bad anneal - again somebody I
don't know says but so what right that's
it says that's a millionaire NFL player
using his celebrity to take a stand
regular folks can't do that can we but
take a look at some of the young women
who are out there today saying hashtag
I'm with cap they're from girls club and
why and it's a bunch of young girls they
look like everybody in the picture looks
like the black it says hashtag I'm with
cap we know our rights
thanks Colin thanks for what thanks for
what did he give you any money or
something I liked it did he fund your
club like if you fail I assume Girls
Club is actually like a 501c3 I like
this one says he took a kneel knee for
me I'll take a stand for him hashtag
Kaepernick did he really take a knee for
you like what did he do for you what was
accomplished for you random dude wearing
a shirt that was apparently a muumuu
from Drew Carey's mom on the show like
what exactly is this
he took a knee for me I'll take a stand
for it like what knee did he take for
you what change has Colin Kaepernick
effectuated any eye things gotten better
for black people because of Colin
Kaepernick I missed it and Francis
Maxwell finally says if people rallying
to support a man who protested injustice
upsets you but the injustice doesn't you
are part of the problem again name the
unjustice and I am happy to protest it
with you but don't tell me that's an
injustice because the second-string
quarterback who can't throw a forward
pass can't get a job because he also
alienates fans because he sits for the
national anthem
okay so again that's step number one and
Democrats plan to alienate all America
is to pick issues like Colin Kaepernick
and Confederate statutes okay step two
is to continue to pick the worst
candidates you can possibly find so in
in step two mint last year picking
Hillary Clinton they're still trotting
out Hillary Clinton as though she's a
thing so Hillary Clinton the audio from
her new book what happened which I
really think it should be call what the
hell happened but it's called what
happened and here is audio of Hillary
Clinton reading from what happened by
Hillary Rodham Clinton the only book
that she's ever gonna sell by the way
because like all her other books are
garbage but I love that she says maybe
her big problem is that she didn't call
Trump of --crepey yes your big problem
Hillary is that you didn't play the
woman card enough I'm sure that was it
I'm sure that if you had only done this
that would have changed everything
it was incredibly uncomfortable he was
literally breathing down my neck my skin
crawled it was one of those moments
where you wish you could hit pause and
ask everyone watching well what would
you do
do you stay calm keep smiling and carry
on as if he weren't repeatedly invading
your space or do you turn look him in
the eye and say loudly and clearly back
up you creep
get away from me I know you love to
intimidate women but you can't
intimidate me so back up okay so what I
love about that is that that's such a
jerk store response all right it's like
a year after this happened and now she
finally came up with the response she
should have said because if she had said
that by the way it would have gone over
like in Buster's it really would have I
mean she would have done a lot better to
strike back at Trump by using sort of
trumpian language but she didn't also I
have a hard time believing that Hillary
Clinton has a problem hanging around
creepy men her husband is an alleged
rapists gang okay if you're talking
about people who have literally breathed
down her neck last time Bill Clinton
tried to breathe down her neck she
tossed a lamp at him
so this routine where she was really
victimized by Donald Trump because he
was within four feet of her is really
amazing and this was the lady they
thought was gonna win they thought she
definitely had to win I can't imagine
why she lost and then there's a Hillary
Clinton aide who was out there yesterday
saying that Hillary would have won if
not for Russia yeah I keep banging this
from you idiots do you think she could
have won if Russia didn't hack the
election yes
you think she's somebody powder that
guy's forehead I think there are a
number of factors including Jim Comey
Putin not minding his business
third the historical curse of third term
I think any of those things if you could
change them a she lost by 70,000 votes
in three state ok so again they're just
gonna keep complaining about this which
means they're gonna keep picking bad
candidates because of the closer they
think this election was the more they
think that they don't have to change
anything and that's what they're doing
now so who are the bad candidates
they're gonna pick well they're talking
out Kamala Harris seriously like the
senator from here from my great stupid
state of California Kamala Harris
they're gonna pick that trash heap yeah
this lady who legitimately can't string
together three tweets without making a
big boo-boo Kamala Harris was a garbage
Attorney General and now she's made her
entire name on being a black woman in
the United States Senate saying things
that are saying things that are
outrageous and the entire Democratic
Party cheers for her because
intersectionality whoo she's black she's
a woman whoo whoo okay here is what the
polls say about Trump versus Kamala
Harris right now Bernie Sanders would
run against Trump
his last poll I saw Bernie Sanders would
win 53 239 53 239 if Joe Biden were to
run against Donald Trump he would win 51
to 38 and if Kamala Harris were to run
against Trump she would be dead even
with him at 41 to 40 so which one of
those three candidates are the Democrats
looking most seriously at yeah they're
looking at Kamala Harris they're looking
at Cory Booker they're looking at all
the people who fulfill the minority
checklist this is what they're
interested in because they're dumb so
that's step two pick bad issues to pick
bad issues with step one pick pad
candidates is step two okay step three I
will get to in just a moment but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at up side so as I have been
telling you for a while the best way to
save money when you travel is going to
upside calm you can buy flights
individually or hotels individually from
upside but you can also you can also
bundle them and that's really what saves
you the serious cash it's great for
business travel particularly last-minute
business travel and the more you bundle
the more you save in you also get a gift
card from places like amazon.com so the
way this works is use your company
credit card in order to book the airline
and then you have an account on the up
side comm website and boom an Amazon
gift card just pops right up in your
account and you are free to use that not
your company you are personally free to
use that they have expert navigators who
are there to help you book the right
flight and the right hotel 24/7 they
give you all the options if you fly into
a different Airport if you stay at a
different hotel if you choose a
different time or a different day they
have people who are available by phone
by chat by social and email to help you
all the way through it's basically a
concierge service it's fantastic right
now give them a try when you use promo
code Bennett upside calm you are
guaranteed to get at least a $100
amazon.com gift card on your package
purchase that is code been to get a $100
gift card for free to make sure that you
use the promo code at checkout at upside
calm and you get that $100 amazon.com
gift card for free on your package of
purchase purchase minimum purchase is
required you can see the site for
complete details you save on your flight
you save on your hotel and you get the
the gift card kickback to you personally
which is pretty awesome upside calm
use that promo code then okay so step
three step one again to recap step one
was pick on popular issue step to pick
on popular candidates step three
be a dumbass fascist okay so this is the
new thing that the left has decided
they're going to do over the last few
years you know they're gonna shut down
people like me when I go to speak at UC
Berkeley or they're gonna protest
outside but not protests get violent
they're going to try to use the
mechanisms of law in order to shut down
people from speaking it's really insane
most Americans are not interested in
shutting down free speech what's funny
is that overall most Americans are not
interested in shutting down free speech
but they're all in favor of shutting
down speech from the other side so this
is why we have checks and balances in
this country it's why we have a bill of
rights in the first place if it were up
to people on the right there was a poll
that said that I think it was a
plurality of right-wingers would be in
favor of shutting down CNN poll on the
left I'm sure would be a plurality would
be in favor of shutting down FoxNews
we're all in favor of shutting each
other up everyone's a little fascist
except that when it comes to the broad
principle we're not if you ask them are
you in favor of shutting down free
speech they'll say no and that is the
protection for free speech we can't rely
on each other's good will and good
nature to protect each other we have to
rely on the fact that we know that if we
and if we attempt to encroach it on
somebody else's free speech they will
encroach on ours well the left has
decided this is now going completely out
the window there's an op-ed in the The
Washington Post I think yesterday
talking about how free speech should go
by the wayside for certain college
speakers right that the free speech
doesn't apply to people who are speaking
hate speech this is a new talking point
so here for example is a columnist from
Law News which is supposed to be a legal
outlet her name is Lauren anos and chews
on with Tucker on Fox News last night
and here she is basically saying that
free speech should not be defended if
it's speech that she doesn't like in
many of these cases with these white
supremacist groups if you look at their
mission statements you will see that
their underlying mission basically is
genocide it has to be taken in that
context ok so just because their
underlying mission is gross does not
mean that they are actually violating
free scream free speech protections it
doesn't I mean lots of people say gross
things all the time that I hate and
despise including white supremacist and
neo-nazis
and they say this stuff all the time but
that has no
impact on whether that is protected
speech or not what the left is trying to
do is declare the Donald Trump is the
real threat to free speech so they can
shut down Trump they're trying to
declare that the right is the real
threat to free speech so they can shut
down the right so here is a perfect
example of this on ABC there is this
commentator whose name is she's the
senior White House correspondent
nationally named Cecilia Vega and she
was on Good Morning America and she
suggested that Trump's speech in which
he ripped on the media would should
actually be illegal it's basically
incitement well George this was
incitement plain and simple I turned my
cell phone camera on the crowd just so
you could see the reaction there as we
were on the stage that's what it looks
like when the president turned the crowd
turns the crowd on you the president
said that journalists hate this country
that's what he told this crowd this was
an assault that went on and on and on
and George I've got to tell you this one
felt different it really feels like a
matter of time frankly before someone
gets hurt
okay so I love that the left is willing
to say this it was only a matter of time
until some Bernie Sanders supporters
snapped and tried to shoot a bunch of
Republican Congress people but didn't
hear any of this talk from the left but
it's only with regard to the right and
this is the new talking point is that
it's not free speech for you because
everything you say is incitement
everything I say is true and wonderful
and glorious but everything you say is
incitement Democratic Representative
John Garamendi from California he says
the same that he actually said that
Trump's attacks on the media it was just
like Hitler it was exactly like Hitler
let me explain man that is totally
totally out of control and engaged in a
rhetoric that slams the press which by
the way happens to be the very first
thing that a dictator will do to secure
his position is to G legitimize the
press and Trump has been at that for his
entire campaign in fact his entire
president don't you understand he must
be shut up because she's trying to
delegitimize us in this nonsense where
the left suggests that everything the
right says is an incitement listen I
don't like a lot of what Trump said at
that rally I talked about it on the show
but it was not incitement you know later
in the show I'm gonna do the big ideas
we do on Thursdays here I'm going to
explain to you what the legal standard
for incitement is so that you know so
you don't fall prey to the stupidity of
people who say things like fire and
crowded theater and have no idea what
the hell they're talking about maybe the
background on what the law says about
all of this but suffice it to say what
Trump did the other night was not actual
incitement it was not incitement to
under the law okay so those are the
three things first three steps and we
get to the fourth in a second so first
three steps were pick unpopular issues
pick horrifying candidates and then be a
fascist okay step four is I think the
most telling one of all but for that
you're gonna have to go and subscribe so
$9.99 a month gets you a subscription to
daily wire you get the rest of this show
live on video later when we post it you
get it free of the ads that I that I
talked about on the show you also get
Andrew Clavin still alive that's
happening in about an hour here you get
Michael Knowles's show live god help us
at 12:30 today Cassy Dillon is sitting
in here and I think she's on Michael
Moses show later so that's a double
recommendation for not watching but if
you do want to watch then you can
subscribe for $9.99 a month and check
that out also rid of the annual
subscription get all those things plus
the website for free all of these
wonderful things and you get this this
tumbler did you see it magically up here
this tumbler is so incredible and it
doesn't even have to be present and it's
still there it's there in heart and mind
no one brought this here and just put it
on the desk in the middle of the show
because we had forgotten it or anything
okay it was just it wasn't there and
then it was there that's how great this
tumbler is it's where you need it to be
at all times for 99 dollars annually you
get this the magical leftist tears hot
or cold tumbler it will make your life
better you'll never have to look for it
because it just appeared wherever you're
looking it's actually slightly creepy
open up a closet boom there it is you
get up in the morning go in the bathroom
boom it's on top of the toilet you just
never know but it's great you're gonna
love it ninety-nine dollars a year
gets you the subscription plus this the
greatest of all tumblers ever created by
God or man so you'll get all of those
things or if you just want to listen
later on iTunes or SoundCloud go over
there subscribe leave us a review we
always do appreciate it
it helps us with the rankings so thank
you for that and the end we are the
largest and fastest-growing conservative
talk show podcast on the interwebs in
America in the world in the universe
anywhere
you
all right so we were now finishing the
the square dance of idiocy from the
Democratic Party how they are blowing
all of their political capital on
nonsense again pick on popular issues
pick crappy candidates be a fascist and
finally claim you are objective yes this
is the big one so last night I was on
CNN with Don Lemon and Don Lemon you
recall we played it on the show the
night before he had gone on this long
rant about Trump how Trump was crazy and
how Trump was was attacking the media
and how this was evil and insane and how
he was mentally unstable and also so I
was on with lemon and I said to Don Don
I don't think that you're doing yourself
a service when you do this
Trump's entire case is that you guys are
emotionally biased against him they have
an animus against him a specific hatred
for him and that you react emotionally
to everything he says and that you don't
give him a fair shake because you don't
like him or you don't like his issues
and Don says no no it's not that I don't
like him I just think that he lies say
well then why don't you just fact check
him in calm and clean manner instead of
questioning his mental health for
example and then he I said listen his
whole case about Confederate statutes
for example is that you are stumping for
a position while proclaiming that you're
not and Don says well you know I have a
view on it but doesn't make me biased so
well Don let me ask you a question do
you want the Confederate statues to go
down or not and Don gives a long
explanation about why Confederate
statues are evil and racist and then he
says but I don't really have a
perspective on it I said Don really like
you really don't have a perspective this
is the problem okay so the media
proclaimed themselves objective and then
they do things that are completely non
objective and then they expect us all to
fall for it
this is the chief critique I don't spend
a lot of time on this program ripping on
MSNBC I spent a lot of time on CNN or
the New York Times for The Washington
Post because MSNBC does not claim to be
objective I laugh at the people on MSNBC
but I don't spend a lot of time trying
to suggest that they are doing something
dishonest cuz they're not if Rachel
Maddow says I'm of the left here's my
perspective she's wrong but she's honest
if people on CNN say I have no
perspective I am just I was bestowed by
God with the wisdom and ability to
objectively remove myself from
situations and speak clearly and truly
about things without dint of perspective
it's nonsense it's a nonsense and so you
see the same media claiming their
objective going nuts on Trump and this
allows Trump to win Trump's entire
battle against the media is lent
credence by the ineffective silly
of the media claiming that their
objective so anderson cooper who claims
he's an objective journalist this was
last night on his show this is like
someone who's objective with regard to
trump supporters of the president say
his base doesn't care if the president
lies or not and many republicans believe
him over the media reporting about it so
be it
but even those who don't care if he lies
have to at some point wonder what drives
it what is it that makes someone so
uninhibited so untethered by facts and
the truth not just in random tweeds
pounded out in the early morning hours
while the president's watching morning
news programs but in settings like last
night lying directly to those who
support him the most
as one trump biographer joins us later
tonight said it might be fruitless to
get inside the man's head better just to
look at what he does and when you do
that a thread becomes clear whether it's
insisting his inauguration crowds were
the biggest even though they weren't or
that he won a historic electoral vote
victory which he didn't or that he said
all the right things about a victim of
domestic terrorism when so many
americans clearly believe he did not
with President Trump there's always one
constant himself okay so here's the
thing
what Anderson Cooper is saying forget
about whether it's true or false for a
second because I think some of the
critique here is actually not wrong I
think some of its overblown but I think
some of its right I think Trump
obviously is an incredibly narcissistic
guy a very egocentric guy who takes
himself far too seriously I think all of
that's true but I am an opinion
commentator Anderson Cooper is a
quote-unquote journalist he's a
quote-unquote objective journalist the
media by proclaiming that they are
objective end up destroying their own
credibility because how can we trust
them to tell us the truth when they're
not even telling us the truth about
themselves at Joe Scarborough makes the
same mistake joe scarborough's a little
better because at least Scarborough is
pretty clearly an opinion guy but you
know Scarborough I mean you talk about
credibility problems listen I don't mind
Joe Scarborough all that much from time
to time but this is a guy who spent a
lot of the primary season telling us how
Donald Trump was wonderful and great and
shorting it up with him and doing full
events with him and now look at him
James clapper said in August 2017 was
identical to what Michael Hayden warned
about in August of 2016 and you know you
can go back and look at the transcripts
mica was saying watch out America watch
out Republicans you better not do this
is what you really want to do
and I guess what's chilling is that
Americans enough Americans did want that
they don't care okay
again this lament would have more teeth
if you hadn't propped the guy up for a
year when you use that when the media do
these sorts of things all they end up
doing is promoting Trump cuz Trump says
you guys are dishonest and he's right
there is a baseline level of dishonesty
with the media the problem for Trump is
that his critique goes further than that
he says not that you guys are dishonest
about yourselves but everything you say
is infused with lies that's not true
some of the stuff they report is true in
fact most of the stuff I'm gonna say
it's something that's very unpopular in
right-wing media to say but this is true
okay here is the fact the New York Times
and The Washington Post these newspapers
that we think are wildly biased in to
the left and we hate they are biased
they are to the left if they were not
expending hundreds of millions of
dollars on reporters the news business
would be significantly poorer the fact
is that sites like mine over at say Lee
Weyer okay we're a vastly growing web
site we have something like 65 million
pageviews in the last month and 16
million unique visitors were a very very
large website can we rely on the
reporting of other sites in order for us
to supplement our own commentary
everyone does this okay so the idea that
everything that you read in the media is
not true it's not true okay that's not
true
everything you read in the media may be
infused with bias but that doesn't mean
it's untrue this is where Trump's
critique goes off the rails it is fair
to call out the media for their bias it
is not fair to say that they are lying
all the time because that is not true
and that is not accurate but when the
media play into that by refusing to
acknowledge their own bias all they're
doing is lending Trump credibility the
more animated they get the more
emotional they get the less they engage
in fact checking and the more they
engage in shouting and screaming the
more they end up destroying than their
own credibility and lending credence to
everything that Trump accuses them of is
what I said to Lemon last night I said
to Don listen dude you actually want to
you actually want to defeat Trump I know
you do like if you actually wanted to
feed Trump all you have to do is
something very simple turn the emotion
down to one and from the fact checking
up to 10 because right now all I'm
hearing is the fact-checking at one and
the emotion at ten and that's what
everyone else is hearing too and so it
sounds like you guys are just slap
fighting each other okay time for some
things I like things I hate and then
I'll explain to you in the big idea what
the legal standard for actual incitement
is under the Constitution okay so first
things I like so thanks to president
Trump looking directly into the solar
eclipse
like Emperor Magda Magda we are doing
things related to blindness this week so
then the most famous blind person in
history is of course Homer and his best
book is the Iliad the epic poem The
Iliad it really is an easy read believe
it or not I know a lot of people don't
like to read poetry but it's not really
poetry it's an adventurous story that's
told in meter and it is fantastic the
reason that it's told that way of course
is because originally it wasn't written
originally it was essentially a song and
people memorized it and handed it down
just like their portions of the Bible
that are song because it was easier for
people to remember that is also true
with regard to to a lot of ancient
literature was written in meter and
poetry is one of the reasons why for
example when you read the Bible the way
that it was handed down there's an
actual song to it like when I dude my
bar mitzvah parsha and when I did my
portion in my Torah portion from the
Bible there's an actual tune that you're
taught and so you can actually remember
what it is that you're reading that when
you read from a Torah scroll not to get
sidetracked when you read from a Torah
scroll there are actually no vowels in
no point and there's no punctuation so
that means the extract to memorize the
vowels and the punctuation
that's because of oral transmission for
thousands of years it's actually very
expensive and difficult to write a Torah
okay the same is true for the Iliad
where a lot of it was memorized and
handed down but it is a wonderful
expression of the ancient ideas of
heroism and valor and a fascinating look
into the ancient world the Iliad so go
and get a copy of it and check it out
okay other things that I like so
yesterday I have to say my listeners are
just fantastic so yesterday I called on
you to go out and please make me some
videos of the most wonderful most
wonderful video that I have seen in the
last year and that was this an Tifa
protester getting knocked right in the
balls by a gas canister and it is
fantastic and so some people have
created various versions of this and I
want to show you all of the various
versions that been created and I want to
particularly thank several people who
listened directly to my request and I do
think it will turned out the best my
direct request for this to be set to
Whitney Houston's I will always love you
and we'll play that last because it's
just spectacular it came out just you
guys are great it came out just like I
imagined it
you know I imagined it the picture was
in my head and
just as I imagined it was beautiful it
sprang directly from my head to your
keyboard and now onto your screen that
you are about to watch so first you have
to see this in slow motion because the
slow motion is pretty spectacular okay
so that you know the movie idiocracy
there's a show called the owl my balls
and they say that's sort of the end of
Western civilization yeah that's what
we're gonna do now this is we call the
segment now my balls
okay so this also was great somebody set
this this video to WWE announcing and it
is very very good
[Applause]
okay and then somebody put this little a
little gift together I'm still undecided
on gift for Jeff Betty here is this is
pretty amazing I love it this is a trump
they've flipped around the footage so
that it works visibly Trump is not
actually lefty but here's Trump and for
those who can't see it's Trump golfing
it morphs right into this video it's
pretty spectacular
it's like Trump is knocking the golf
ball right into this guys crotch okay
and then somebody did the the
ever-present internet classic that is
the mashup of the Titanic music with
with pepper balls this guy is bad bit of
golf
[Music]
again I think the best thing about this
is colin kaepernick
apparently found a job rushing this guy
off the field to play after this happen
okay and finally the one that I
requested and I must have gotten 10 to
15 people who actually went ahead and
did this independently of one another
sorry we couldn't coordinate it but
credit to all of you you all get credit
this is one of the versions that was put
out online yesterday I think it is a
fantastic version this is the this is
pepper balls set to Whitney Houston's I
will always love you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
play it again run it back it's not often
you get to laugh at somebody's pain and
it's great it's great so that's uh okay
thank you all for doing your level best
to make dementia puro show great again
fantastic okay time for a quick a couple
quick things that I hate and then I'll
explain to you what legal incitement is
no this doesn't count as legal
incitement this counts as me laughing a
guy getting knocked in the crotch for
kicking gas canisters at the cops
okay so Danvers some things I hate okay
so the first thing is the the CEO of an
of a organization called cloud fair
cloud fair is a hosting hosting
organization and the CEO banned the
neo-nazi website daily stormer suffice
it to say I am not particularly hot on
the daily stormer I think that Nazis are
evil you see this thing on the top of my
head it means that they would have
murdered me right so I'm not big on
neo-nazis I'm not big on Nazis but I'm
also not big on Mathew Prince he's the
CEO of cloud fair so he discussed the
web hosting companies decision to remove
daily stormer from their servers and
here was his explanation
I found the daily Strummer repugnant I
did not shedding a tear that that
content isn't online anymore
but one of my fellow employees came up
to me the day that we we talked took it
offline and said hey is this the day the
internet dies there was no due process
you okay and then he went on to say that
he said I'm deeply concerned I had the
authority and the power to wake up one
morning in San Donna I'm sick of this so
screw them they're off the internet but
he did it anyway and this is the problem
if you'd recognize that your goal here
in a certain a service like cloud fair
which is not an ideological service and
you didn't have any preconditions as to
what could be posted obviously I assume
they still host a bunch of bad sites
things that most people would consider
bad if you are essentially proposing
yourself as an open server
then you're banning people it's not
illegal it's a private company but it
definitely verges on the on the nasty to
to violate your own prescriptions on
free speech because what's to prevent
him from knocking Taylor wire off his
servers if he doesn't like the material
that were posting these these standards
are malleable I wish they weren't I wish
they weren't I think there are things
like daily stormer that virtually
everyone agrees are garbage
but opinions change I mean the fact is
that now if you are anti same-sex
marriage you're considered so bad that
they're gonna get rid of you at Mozilla
right so where where does the standard
actually take place I think this is
dangerous dangerous thinking okay so I
wanna get right to the big idea cuz I
think it's actually important to discuss
this so the big idea today we're gonna
discuss incitement you've heard the
phrase shouting fire in a crowded
theatre this is what people use as an
excuse to shutdown free speech oh the
government should be able to shut you up
because it's just like shouting fire in
a crowded theater no the point
shouting fire in a crowded theater is
that you are number one saying something
that is untrue because if there actually
is a fire then you have to shout fire in
a crowded theater but number two if you
shout fire in a crowded theater not only
does it have to be untrue it also has to
present actual danger the problem with
doing it in a crowded theater is that
presumably people will trample each
other to get out based on a lie that was
the point of the language it comes from
a case called Schenk versus United
States there's a long history in the
country of censorship and then over time
censorship has actually gotten less
stringent not more stringent in the
United States so this case from 1919 the
court ruled that censorship under the
1917 Espionage Act under Woodrow Wilson
Democrat was okay for a pamphlet from
socialists claiming that the draft was a
form of slavery they suggested that the
language created a clear and present
danger of bringing about law breaking
and so Oliver Wendell Holmes wrote the
question in every case is whether the
words used are in such circumstances and
are of such a nature as to create a
clear and present danger so this created
what they call the clear and present
danger standard for what was not
protected by the First Amendment that
create a clear and present danger in
1923 is another case called Gitlow
versus New York and the court held that
using a criminal Anarchy statute to
prosecute people advocating for the
overthrow of the US government was fine
the court said it does not restrain the
advocacy of changes in the form of
government by constitutional and lawful
means when a prohibits is language
advocating advising or teaching the
overthrow of government by unlawful
means the
words imply urging to action Oliver
Wendell Holmes guy who wrote the fire in
a crowded theater line he voted against
this he said that did not create a clear
and present danger where this really was
was rebutted where this entire line of
argument was really rebutted swen people
say fire in a crowded theater really
doesn't apply anymore that's because of
a 1969 case called Brandenburg versus
Ohio Brandenburg v Ohio was a case in
which the Supreme Court held that speech
tending to promote lawlessness or
advocating illegal activity cannot be
restrained by criminal laws unless the
speech quote is directed to inciting or
producing imminent lawless action and is
likely to incite or produce such action
so that's a two prong test right one
then my design is to produce in you some
sort of violence action
I say Cassie go shoot Mathis and that it
has to be likely to actually produce
that right it's likely to incite or
produce such action so I have to make a
strong case for why she should shoot
Mathis like he's doing a crappy job
today right if I do that then maybe it's
illegal but in this particular case the
court found that at KKK rally where
somebody talked about revenge against
the President and Congress if they
continued their scheme of supposedly
oppressing whites they said that is not
incitement under the law so if that's
not incitement under the law nothing
that you saw today nothing from Trump
nothing from Bernie Sanders nothing that
has been said on this program none of
its incitement so next time somebody
says fire in a crowded theater suggest
them they don't know their law the
governing standard is imminent lawless
okay the governing standard is imminent
lawless action likely to incite that's
the standard under Brandenburg versus
Ohio that's legal standard bleph likes
to cite the supreme court okay you can
cite that case back to them because that
is the governing standard not the old
clear and present danger standard that
has largely been changed by Brandenburg
okay so we will be back here tomorrow
and tomorrow thank God is a Friday we're
getting close to the end of the week
folks so be here tomorrow make sure you
subscribe so you can be part of the
mailbag and we'll see you then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]